there's people in Africa that's targeted
minami live yeah I thought that blonde
hair - right
blonde hair and blue eyes how is that
[Music]
you guys are ready
absolutely what's up everybody welcome
to another episode of hot box and I'm
Evan Britain and I'm Mike Tyson like we
got a legend of your bra on man this one
the greatest we got the man Akon welcome
my brother thank you Mike yeah this is
awesome I mean [ __ ] dude
so many hits your music is just like
heard round the world
obviously like that [ __ ] oh my god good
but Mike was just saying something
interesting to you cuz you know you
don't travel with an entourage yeah
you're so listen this isn't just doing
myself when I used to do this solo stuff
that's because I always wanted anyone
know I know what I was doing so much
when I can't give up what you doing
leaving his somebody sneaked up my house
get my car take off this incarnation I
could people are following me he never
loves just security could be cool still
me though have something on you in the
past they should know if you married at
the time doing dirt yeah didn't want
people to know your business that's why
that's why I was always doing anything
but then this is what happened right you
by myself
Sam by myself doing what my runs and I
was a walk I mean to my team my walk and
then somebody approaches you he said
well one moment
I'm doing something but they don't stop
no and you know stuff and anything come
power hit the cuffs is that while you
were saying - yeah you got my shot up
some odds with you yes because I'm this
is what I didn't I thought I had enough
emotional intelligence at the time this
is what I can't believe that the person
I I couldn't even do this it was three
inches no stop no please like no stop
please
yeah you know Wow I wasn't I think I can
handle that
why can't I handle that I wasn't
sophisticated enough Lang Wow
I need to think about that's hard man
that's hard though well actually for me
is easy yeah
how do you handle it up now is a lot
easier for me what is there so many
distractions hmm you don't even notice
me sometimes no I'm not always like this
Mike I just came from a photo shoot
that's why normally I'm as simple as my
cat scary yeah thirsty people around
here no it's a lot there's girls I have
a shoe hmm they definitely out here with
but I mean as you start to move I
realize actually I get less attention
when I'm by myself cuz most people don't
even really know if that's me and then
that comes like are you a con I'm like
nah but I get better right so they never
really know now true fan you can't you
can't run from me no I'd be like I could
look but in a selfie munis take a real
quick yeah so it's like you know yeah
you know you Bobby the weave you get it
but I know before when I was with
entourage there was no question no yeah
and wherever you go there's a parade
yeah and listen right I thought because
I had big I maybe you experienced I
thought because I had big body got that
was scare people
yeah I the tracks that came up I believe
my body go boom boom with car failing
whoa wait for him
what do you mean I can't talk to him go
to writing yeah you know and they scared
me
someone's been bike they weren't talking
give them the pictures don't talk these
guys got weapons and guns and they wanna
think bitching you guys to know you know
45 of them right what them take a
picture yeah right this is crazy
yeah but I realized you know this part
of what we asked for anyway yes life we
chose right here and really believe it
or not we are so blessed our only energy
that we have to actually expose is two
seconds to take a picture it don't cost
you that's nothing it may cost you a
little bit of time but the money you
don't make thinking about how much time
no most people that sit there for I was
hitting the clock for $8 an hour and all
I gotta do is just take a picture with
whoever wants one every once in a while
I'm cool with that
yo who's happy you know left okay I
wonder what those people eating out all
these people would say that's a horrible
job you know I could be like that [ __ ]
him you know he working for two hours
two hours and I was something when other
guys make that wonder they feel like
it's a sucker job I guess it depends on
the person yeah because I mean when I
was working as a stock stocking that
Kroger's before I made it I was cool
down like I was happy yeah late hours
nobody bothered me I just put on my
headphones knock these groceries because
in my mind I knew I'm being prepared for
something bigger
yeah does that make sense like Ron I
kind of felt where I was going and I
knew like these are these are the
moments of discipline that I have to
endure there's no way I'm gonna get
where I'm going without being
disciplined and then can keep the
success yeah that's such a great lesson
bro my mental wouldn't let me work he
said no you never work he said went for
my AK you did you were gonna tell you
never worked in your life if keep
training never after working your life
right it was all about the grind
yeah then that works too yeah that works
too cuz if you don't have a view he's
right and focused right and then focus
plays a huge role cuz we write when you
distracted by so many other things and
not on what you know you what you're
destined for with that talent is
actually gonna be what brings you out
you four hundred percent so for someone
like Mike I think that was the best
strategy for you cuz you're absolutely
the person for me
- I played football okay I play I made
it to the NFL
I had some solid success but you know to
get there was a [ __ ] grind you know
and I you know everything you said
though man
really resonates because it's about that
feeling is a feeling you know I'm
feeling happy no matter what right and
that's really hard for a lot of people
know it understand right now cuz I mean
what is happiness right I mean it
happened yeah it's that happiness yeah
oh that celebration mmm what does that
what is that what is this what is the
meaning of us that work inspires us but
we learn no no meaning of this existence
no I agree it's almost like love right
it's so underrated or overrated for that
matter
yeah like first is like I may be sitting
with someone now we do you know but I
believe that I love because me there's
no like love is the to mean how would
you express it right so put this way
right to me when you say the word love
that's the max feelings go all the way
to the point of love and then it stops
there you don't get no higher mm-hmm
right so you can like really really like
somebody hmm but you don't quite love
them yeah but when you get to that point
where you say I love you that's the
forest feelings go so if a girl comes -
well you don't love me enough well how
much do you love me do you like whoa
hold up first of all what love is this
why did they say love is love you don't
go past that right if you have to say
how much you love somebody you really
express it how much you like someone
right right
you follows in and then expression
depends on the person because some
people like you to be you know like
protective and don't do this do that
because it feels they feel loved when
you you know you feel protective of them
because you thing and then others feel
more loved when you shower them with
yeah you know and that's not love really
and really that's more manipulation yeah
I always thought the definition of love
was when you and someone say this we
made a vow to get married and so we made
that vow and during that private we're
[ __ ] and loving and going to
passionate and fighting them whatever
and then I'm that way is out now yeah we
don't do that no more as much right
are we not as good as we used to cook we
don't get the same inch but we're still
young right right but then that's love
now love begins yeah that's when love
began and that's an amazing point
because that's when you're actually
tested yeah if it's real listen because
they have to be Malone that right
there's some different kind of [ __ ]
[ __ ] for I wasn't right right stops
you from going there nothing stops you
because you still love that person
exactly
you still love that person but listen
right love is interesting because even
though I love her I'll die for
I'll kill for but she's not gonna stop
me from getting that [ __ ] ah because I
got a wife that what it is Mike is that
people know people mistake like love for
urge you know like when you are lost
right yeah you want something when you
urge for it you just have Sawyer that
desire that's not love that's just
what's our hiring and eating yeah you
fought I'm saying but what happens is
people put that all in the same box well
you wouldn't do that if you loved me
yeah and then she's thing but no I
this is interesting I used to think that
too
but I look at I look at women different
look at you I look at I look at
everybody at before everybody was my
competitor my woman guys took off liquor
at me shout think house [ __ ] but now as
I got older everybody became my teacher
right you know my wife
Mike's girlfriend's relationships that
didn't work out although I've learned
some nose and I don't make those
mistakes only if those mistakes are
beneficial towards me I'll make them on
purposely alright you know and I know
how to choose my battles which I never
knew before
I never know how to shut my [ __ ]
mouth you're just like oh I I didn't
want to be happy I wanted to be right
yeah you know that's not interesting
that's interesting because it raises a
point too because I think the dynamics
between what love is what urge is and
how it's understood by your partner
makes a difference because today and
it's so weird that we create all these
rules in life without putting nature
into account because manages natural
breeders by nature we can't help ya this
is what our large we are is biological
like we can't even control it like
imagine you walking down the sidewalk
with your lady and you holding hands and
you see a bad chick walk past if she
looks at you say boy you better not look
not turn yeah oh it's gonna take
everything in your power not to turn
over your so but you don't know how
articles that urge you is that's the
nature side that no control no it's not
even ego its nature Mike the pranic okay
let's put his way let's put ego aside
your girl's not even with you alright
you put a thousand guys a thousand guys
on one corner and you let one bad chick
walk pass I guarantee you a thousand
here it's gonna turn him like do your
girl not even there now it's just the
thought of wow you don't even know why
you looked on cuz we don't know who we
are
most people don't understand who they
are in fact most of all the women don't
understand men the way we understand
them and we don't understand them the
way they understand this no we do
understand them see that's the key
that's department lay why you miss plane
why right now if you were to look at the
capacity of women we all will agree that
women are a lot smaller than we are I
mean it's okay it's okay
I agree with this okay disagree that
yeah no no no they also I agree we are
smart in this they are smart enough not
really our yeah right mentally they can
take a lot more pain than we are
mentally yes when it comes to the brain
or to physical they give birth bro
physical birthday and you put a man in
the room and you're both torture them to
telling somebody the man with Toby for a
100 to say they more tolerant to pain
physically I believe that's believe
that's where I was going next they have
this commitment of loyalty within them
and it's more they more committed than
men could ever be 1,000% right so you
got and then when you look at the
population that's 15 to 1 in the world
for every one male there's 15 women in
service so they outnumber us they're a
lot smarter than we are
they're way more physically and mentally
tolerant to pain than we are and most of
all of anything they're more committed
than guys could ever be how is it that
this is a man's world it's only because
we understand them more than they
understand us and we utilize what we
know to manipulate to control them
because the one thing we do know without
a doubt is that men I mean women are
move to emotion that's their only
weakness our biggest weapon against them
is how we make them feel because they're
natural mothers which goes back to
nature again because they're motherly
Natura book love is the one thing that
can make a woman do what she doesn't
want to do and we notice so we use that
as a way of utilizing the control of the
world that's interesting we're not even
know are we doing it I just know this I
woke up this mode listen to wind you out
the dryer yeah what was the name tired
dryer and normally I used to have a
summation right before her and wedding
day my affirmation was what's up and
when I opened my eyes in the morning
what do I see and everything I see is
inferior to me right and then I listen
to Wayne Dyer and he says something when
you open your eyes what did you see look
I've thought about my little egotistical
[ __ ] after me and he says you see
perfection how could how could
everything be how could I be superior
than everything that's perfected and he
looked and then you become humbled
that's what this world is this is
perfect you know we don't like it but
because of how we feel about this is
perfection
yeah this is perfection he knew what it
was when I go when I was in the
Caribbean I was saying to myself this is
what I see I think I'm smart I think I'm
in the vehicle like this right I think
I'm deep I like this why the [ __ ] why
does the water stop right here why do
they keep coming to ocean you keep come
what doesn't stop right here like I'm
deep right and it's just simple because
this is perfection hmm that's why it's
perfect yeah it's just that simple
that's perfected I'm trying to look for
some deep meaning here yeah yeah but you
know what's crazy that's a [ __ ] great
question it is a great crush even
scientists can't answer that because
it's perfect exactly and the further you
go out the deeper it gets which makes
the water the mass so much more exactly
stop right there sure they would drown
me right
Yeah right every fan everything is
perfected to be the work but listen this
is all of course you know this if every
ant died the [ __ ] world will die if
every bird died this world without
everything please if every human died
this world with flourish why is that are
we that bad are we a [ __ ] cancer all
we really a cancer man this thing but
we're be weirder that's what people are
where germs aren't we hold in the planet
back if we all perished we hope the
[ __ ] planet we just go up boom and
flurries but we're [ __ ] sucking it
out you're killing it
well we have the power to do ultimate
great as well as well as the ship and
[ __ ] burn it all to the ground you
know we have both of those and we could
be here and helping it we could be the
Gardeners of this place yeah greed won't
allow that don't ya cuz I interests
before anything or anyone or any being
for that matter we're always looking to
how we I'm Italian brother Chi taste
yeah I can't put my finger on
I'm not intelligence but I think greed
balance stuff man I can't put my finger
on I hate greed too but it balances
imagine if everybody had money
oh man if everybody had money woah who
are we gonna relate to when I'm home or
to wash my car Who am I gonna tell hey
like my dog oh hey you gonna pick the
kids up man who all have my magical wife
[ __ ] you - they [ __ ] you then you always
have to love each other honestly I think
if we all had money the world people no
way no cuz didn't ever won't be no ego
see he goes what separates us excuse me
ego is the only thing that separates us
because think about it right if
everybody in here was a billionaire just
think about it money wasn't a problem
for ya yeah damn I can't pick up my
salmon you might pick them up for me of
course well you got to pick them up from
you ain't got no worries you ain't got
[ __ ] to do anyway but that's ego though
so you think about if that's still all
ego because when you come from a place
to just pure love you do anything for
anybody you just purely love uh-huh I
once asked you didn't ask questions of
Mario was to call us and ask us to do
anything what were you gonna do done
you ain't gonna send nobody else to do
it Wacka that's your man you want to
make sure it gets done when I
accidentally do furnace right all right
it's done so when everybody's in a place
where I'm not being judged I'm being
treated as equal as you it opens the
door for me to be Who I am and allow
people to love me in the way that I need
to be loved
yeah and vice versa so if everybody
honestly the only thing that separates
us in this world is classes yes I
believe that right listen this is so
interesting with other things to
religion but it goes all the way back to
on yeah because once you could like
prime example I know as much people
could say okay Muslims Jews don't get
along Christians don't get them they
still marry
Muslims and Jews that are married right
and know in the Holy Land right so this
is just all it goes back to evil all
over again because ego is all about
power at the end of the day who controls
what those who so when it goes to
religions and separate in our lap
because when you put all these religious
together they all believe in the same
computes yeah we believe we all believe
in a higher being not because the
languages one may call them allow me one
may call him John one may call him God
one may call him you know like what
everyone has their own meaning for that
higher being but we all believe in
something higher than us so in actuality
religion is all to save me just how you
were sure I agree with them but it's a
psychological difference right no
separation 100% you know because the
people in it who are very dogmatic who
believe what they believe they go oh
that person's not like me it's very
different right
amazing where are you from originally
that's right that's right yeah dude
you're doing something incredible right
now you're building a city he built this
video it's built on building tell us
about that cuz mike has got some
projects in the work amen so you know
this is his dream room like I'm calling
it like his future right here and I'm
seeing these these resorts
I mean cannabis like just I was like I
didn't even know Mike was into all this
like I'm so proud centers yeah man this
is gonna be the future of living right
really a thing really is it's like an
organic Cosmo lifestyle right the cosmos
I can't even put together but you know
that means I know exactly what you mean
sinner go actor yeah big-time
it's huge so me what I've been doing you
know I was I was more on the resort side
we building small cars like trying to
reunite us trying to you know inject
excitement in the tourism all throughout
Africa starting with Senegal
lover and I realized that majority of
Africa's self isn't just
just not developed but I'm reaching I'm
also seeing how all the resources from
Africa's being pulled from Africa to
develop all these other countries
everybody the beginning a time Rome
before Roman since they'll write what
was there what some people before not in
Syrians know before this Assyrian
respite Amiens come on with subscribing
they're like the water people but anyway
right yeah they've been using they know
how to do this since the beginning of
time it's been happening for a long time
beginning and my whole thing was okay
Sumerian Sumerians just to begin they
knew about resources you know thousands
of years before Christ they know about
resources right have slave labor for
resources right that's crazy yeah yeah
so ultimately the idea for me was okay
the only thing that separates African
citizens from benefiting from this it's
two reasons one is the fact that they're
just uneducated to what those resources
are and how much value those resources
have and - they never utilize the
resources in any way because they
couldn't define what that was and how
much value it could be used so my thing
was okay cool instead of buying land in
America where they're gonna tax it and I
can't own anything under six feet of the
ground anyway I don't really own the
land I might as well go where I know for
sure I'm an owner layer number one and
number two I can utilize the resource
itself to rebuild the country that's
building everybody else's country so
that's why I wanted to create that akon
futuristic city and start in Africa
because I know like probably South
Africa's creating four or five
billionaires a year hmm like we have
more billionaires in Africa than we have
in China then just a lot of people don't
even know yeah right so if you set the
standard to create and most of them
don't even bank in Africa which is crazy
yeah they're baking in Europe banking
and you know in Swiss banking in the UK
like nobody banks in Africa's there's
never been a solid stable currency
throughout the whole continent no one
trusts you and no is one reason why I
said okay we got to create a coin which
will be the cryptocurrency that bypasses
fiat currency alternative
you follow saying it's a big web within
the city the currency and then now you
get the population and you literally
like just charge them up and empower
them to be the ones that manage it build
it and living it it's [ __ ] awesome
man yeah how's it going it's going
amazing man it's going amazing we just
got all the Provost's for the whole site
to build out we got the master plan
approved by the government and now
although you know just getting all the
investors to come on board and know what
I noticed too for my travels in like the
Caribbeans and heylia's YP without
afraid of [ __ ] oh yeah they get them for
anybody so wait I'm in the jungles right
I'm not getting out the car you see why
we're drinking establishes out there
what do you think why why they want to
get away from the world at the end
anyone to experiment he went explore do
other stuff and like after they're not
normally have done before
Jamaica's well folks should be scared
and nothing like oh because you know you
know ancient Chinese one of the Chinese
emperors he took you know 30,000 people
around the world on all those treasures
chips yeah he went around it took 30
years yeah and they didn't do anything
they didn't do any of the you know like
the Roman Empire just expanding and no
you know taking over destroying you know
indigenous cultures and making them
become assume the role of Rome Inc they
put the damn the war was beneath them
when they from the 38th expand they put
the wood and had
no off for them right but they believed
it's interesting because they had a very
superior way of thinking as well to the
Chinese no the Romans the Romans well
listen for sure um this is interesting
that we will fit that because you know
during the Roman time with Hannibal the
war would handle when a some unified
Rome same time to China at the same
exact time unity that china unified the
self interesting same exact yeah it did
the same exact time
mm so what 221b sees on the same time
both interesting and thing what at the
same time that's a trip dude I mean that
that's I don't even know what to say
about that it's it's an interesting is
it something in the brain is it
something you know what us honestly this
is something that I think we need to
like just dissect a white person to find
out I think um they just have this they
have this very inquisitive way of living
huh right like and I think has a lot to
do with history too because sometime you
know patterns of history will condition
you all the way down to your core genes
as to how you react how you think what
you're afraid of what you're not uh hung
you know what white people it was
different because they've always ruled
the world right so they never had reason
to fear because everywhere they came
they either took over and became
superior or they was when they're right
you're talking about I'm as far as
alright the written words concerns
history with the same because you know
we're all related right you know they
came from us somebody producer somebody
but just a white shoe white jean because
the white gene is recessive oh the white
gene you know the white gene could be in
one of us and probably come out of
thousands here delay it later hmm
you know this is gonna always appear
when it's in your system it's gonna over
the page so no one's gonna come out you
know yeah I don't know why is someone I
don't think it Hawaiian how did it get
created like that
yeah the world it goes right back to
perfection again you never really like
you can't answer a lot of questions like
I got I got like you see how dark I am I
got a lot lighter since I've been in
living in America but I used to be a lot
darker right there's people in Africa
that's darker than me with blue eyes
yeah I thought that blonde hair too
right
blonde hair and blue eyes dark as me
what is that about like wait what's that
about a man no bigger than we can ever
imagine whatever man like how are you I
didn't want to touch like how is that
possible yeah like he's imaginative
black ass [ __ ] like naturally this is
how they were born yeah yeah it's
creepier you see some time you see a
model of something that came from right
let's do dance I'm wearing a
blond-haired blue-eyed you know we all
about genetics I know because we
literally sit there and we we we we're
the ones that actually categorize
genetics because not being scientists or
even knowing any history about how life
works
[ __ ] period we say okay cool because you
may have blonde hair and blue eyes okay
you boot you belong to this class now
imagine if one of those black
[ __ ] a blond hair blue eyes
popped up over here what class are you
going to actually put in here yeah well
you know also there's this new study
came out about aboriginals right they
don't share any they don't share any DNA
similar DNA with any other group of
people on the planet in the library some
dead descendants from Eve Aborigines or
it could be alien no there which means
ascendant from Eve they're their
ancestors but how would that explain
them not having any gene that
corresponds what how is though you don't
say this I know you did it they're the
divine people that been stripped of
their dignity hmm you know when when
when they when British put all those
people in Australia to be prisoners and
that's a prison Island
right and for the abuser there ever is
new people but these people were the New
Zealand is ripped apart
raped and killed them poodle eyes don't
you know that's just crazy
yeah these are like hiding a
conversation yeah save the rich like
knew of that song again I remember the
song was a song thanking God for saving
the rich like me it was a guy used to be
a slaver and then he said he wrote that
song [ __ ] what was that song to save a
wretch like me I forgot was a great song
save a wretch like me
yeah [ __ ] it was a slave song too but
amazing great so he wrote Amazing Grace
was the guy that was a slave or he's a
slave kidding the boat and slave him do
whatever he can in a boat that was his
life and slave that and then um he sort
of right and fell in love with the
people and said they were so beautiful
and we were guerrillas and and he wrote
that song and he Wow whoa he took the
rest of his life he was you know he
became a monk yeah what's that
um what do you call it a church I guess
it was well against a difference like
that's really behavior the slave of
stuff we need a vote that great song he
seemed there like wow that's interesting
yeah man we wake up though sometimes
that one moment in your life that just
transpose this the whole way if they can
move in behavior yeah everybody has that
turning point you know but I don't think
is my turning point was when I got
locked up I just burst wasn't saying it
huh you know it's like it's almost like
go through oh I don't know I was coming
right out of high school or this thing
like in Africa we didn't have no birth
certificates well how you meet Tito oh
man Tito's like boost Tito
he's uh he's like my brother okay and
when I came up from New Jersey when we
came from Africa I went from there to
st. Louis first okay and then my pipes
got a job to be a professor at
University of Miami
okay Miami Miami a lot of fun huh good
yeah Jersey was the only place they're
upside down right completely upside down
right so then around the time when we
was in Miami that early 80 stage you had
Miami being um you could say invaded by
the hotel's
people was kind of getting killed right
in front of everybody right no in broad
daylight
yeah in front right a cocaine Cowboys
yeah cocaine Cowboys Yeah right so my
pops and moms like man cuz I'm afraid
for y'all walk home from school and just
be innocent bystanders
so boom she sent us out to New Jersey
huh not realizing just New Jersey was
even worse cuz yeah man access see there
you see and you watch it but there's no
access in New Jersey with street access
so now mind you mr. right so now I'm in
Jersey I don't really speak how English
is good but it's like and the graph of
Jersey says write very aggressive so
people never really and then I was
living like literally right in Jersey
City where's more dominant Porto Ricans
so I was probably the only African in
that little circle
and literally moves like two blocks from
Tito he saw me riding my bike was
playing ball and at the time to time
which is really active he's like he was
like the most popular older brother in
that little area he would always see me
just like kind of by myself lucky I go
by the gym and I'd be doing I'm a little
push-ups or whatever the case may be
because I was just trying to get my way
time I see everybody Tito was product at
that time so I was like you know Tito
how you get so big how you get so strong
you know cuz he was skinny but he was
you Kazuki was ridden yeah I was like
you know the six pack it on how did you
do that you know I was young he said
look man I just do my exercising gym and
I was like really so every way today
I'll go to school I would do my
exercises yeah right right
everybody lollygagging I'm doing my
exercises in gym so it got to the point
where I start moving around with them
online but I was still the only black
one in that little circle so every time
I had beef I would reach out to Tito he
called all the Puerto Ricans so then it
becomes like it was crazy crazy back in
me up I'm the only black together all
right so we used to get into all these
little fights at school so then I say
might get my gym teachers like man
listen you what is wrong with you like
you come from Africa you're wasting your
life dealing with these thugs and you're
gonna miss races you're always fighting
what is your problem so he introduced me
to this kickboxing coach in Bayonne Oh
so I started kickboxing and then he
recommended me to Mario [ __ ] right so
now Mario was like listen I heard so
much about you man I feel like I already
knew you didn't Tito put me inside you
know he's one of us so Mario took me in
as one of them so he always kept me
grounded put your on your way now he was
with you he's like he's like he's like
our Godfather right he owned this whole
block on ton of the Avenue which looks
like literally a danger zone like when
you if anybody is not from there drive
over there you'd be scared to death
you'd be super nervous because there's
nothing surrounding you it's just notice
is crazy all right
so then whenever we would have beef in
in the street
Mario be like look just bring it
so now we wouldn't fight outside no more
we had a problem we just go tomorrow you
go to ringside and everybody they just
Duke it out man I don't know where I'll
be but they come back later I come and
they show me what happened in the film
you know Mike did you guys cross paths
right right it's a part of that DNA okay
Mike that's why I said Mike was like
literally our like because everywhere
you going whether he was at the bar or
in the gym Mike's photos was everywhere
so we just knew like and everybody
aspired to be like Mike so the the fight
concept it not only didn't get us out of
the street but it made us feel like okay
it all fails we all gonna be boxing or
kickboxing or whatever Wow you know it
was crazy so that energy just kind of
round me up so I got into it really
heavily I end up like dude I mean like
you have a box for anything
oh yeah I'll show you the tapes like
litters never lost it when I was kicked
bucks I never lost no fun oh yeah right
so crazy so now all that's happening
then you know I make a little money I
moved to Newark and buy a barbershop so
now I have a nice little blob of [ __ ]
know what you [ __ ] know cuz even
worse than yeah so I got my shop up
three months six months it goes out
shootouts on that corner every [ __ ]
frog end up shoot they'd enough shooting
the shop up I had to close it out so now
I'm looking for work I meet another dude
does a partner of mine named Tony who
hires me at his shop and that's where I
met why clever Wow
so Wyclef at the time with his uncle and
his you know cousins yeah the studio
called the book of basement everybody
would go in and you know record whatever
so I'm cutting his hair he's like he'll
come by the studio so I called Tito I
said yo listen this is a new group I
hear they got nice the studio
Tito rhymes with me we go at the time
you know my dad's a jazz musician so I
was very musically inclined and I just
started you know making music in the
basement by day and even I being with
Tito when we hustling our net sizes
musician by date hustler by night right
so that it just kind of generated and
then Tito is like yo you need to focus
on this music [ __ ] you're a lot better
musician than you are and when they say
husband and people being shot at right I
mean that's part of the game you know
some people like me or what is hustling
this is like what is the definition of
that hustling whatever you need whatever
you can do get it yeah by any means
uh-huh that's hustling yeah bottom line
if you're great at you know picking
drugs if you've been right all right
fraud that robbery whatever it is you
know drug money yeah get money that's it
right don't matter figure it out and
make it work don't come back without a
profit you know what I realized my life
you know must my friends I see my
friends right on the weekend on the
weekend always funny got all the money
in the world everything right and then
they got to live the real world then
Monday happens man in the world doing
whatever the next weekend you see him
the same people are not with them no
more
they're dead you know they got different
crooner different people new people the
people really old friends they're dead
from one weekend to the day absolutely
from this while he was also close
because we knew the closer we was the
less the chances would be that we just
stopped falling off and that made us the
most popular well crew it wasn't quite a
game cuz we were like a family
so black royal became like and that's
why we called ourselves blockwork before
like we was the king of the block but
before even before um Peter that people
were dying right there was not yeah he
was dying
it's like Jersey just was crazy man yeah
and then the generation that came after
us was even worse like super super Wars
I don't I don't know what it was it was
just a hunger there was just it was just
you know in our eighteen eighties and we
were coming
our whole thing was just being somebody
this one to be somebody people know I
named [ __ ] they having money and this
one to be for my for that moment we had
no idea we could do for 20 or 40 years
yeah he's also correct that's why I blew
a lot of my money cuz I never thought I
was gonna lift this long right all my
friends at I'm in 1618 instead when I
gonna lose money I think oh my back even
if they're dying from agents tough day
of dying they'll have to be blonde you
think it's either they're doing OD list
and the [ __ ] why they all don't want me
with me live every day like it's my last
ma and I think that's the mine state of
a lot of you know just get okay you know
what are you going to sports you're
going to music yeah or you just somehow
make it they get that first big check
man no no no yeah we have we don't have
a connection with self-love right young
like that from the ghettos do we know
about the only thing we know about
having our guys back right no individual
love and we are hopeless it is our team
it's our team this why's the entourage
is always saying I don't know when I
first came out man huh man I couldn't
walk into the club looks with 5200 guys
with me it's just no way it's impossible
isn't impossible and then when you get
to the club you got another 25 waiting
for you they're already part to call
wait we got you dog we got I know you
must have did this thing if I go to
Russia way I can I go to Russia you know
I don't mind this about us
they got m60 right listen the girls are
not gonna come over here you guys have
to come to you guys you heavy artillery
just and they show it to let you know
yeah well [ __ ] around mean-looking
[ __ ] Russians dude when I hang out
with us right yeah we're trying to have
a good time period they like man
they won't like hired guys yeah yeah you
know but when you're coming up on the
bottom level use that's just yes yeah
these your homeboys yes you turning as I
start to get older start to go through
things start to mature and every once in
a while you say I got to go back home
check on everybody I've got to you have
to well listen that's you know a trip
yeah go back you check and you realize
damn you go back to Jersey yeah I go I
never go to any new york without
stopping just uh-huh always stop go to
ringside eat some screws chicken let's
don't take this out right as funny to
say that because I'm from Brownsville
Brooklyn right and I say to myself why
the [ __ ] why my dad why am i coming to
see these rotten [ __ ] kill you
set you up right with you all day money
with Jeanette in the day there Robbie
all the money my mother that's why I'm
always down with these [ __ ] many
things maybe she [ __ ] shoot me a
little and I think this is who I am
that's why they're after this is where I
am I'm one of the thirty [ __ ] I'll be
talking about make everything right in
this I'm one of them because it goes
everything well no but that's best
anywhere in the world anyway any hours
okay why am i running dirty f- scheming
or they scheming but what I realized oh
but what I realized though we become the
hope yes it was I had a most most
interesting conversation on walkie and I
haven't seen it one of my friends is
seen in ten years locked up I know when
you've been a camera time I'll see you
he sent me I was in a big massive now
you I do everything good yeah so you
need anything you say no I'm wearing
make sure you don't need nothing
well no I'm straight do you need
anything no I'm here to make sure y'all
need her I said but obviously I don't
need yeah how's your family your mom
everybody good you good you don't need
anything right so no I'm here to make
sure you and I said when you say that
what do you mean yeah he said brah
anything you need I got you I'm work
anybody for you
murk means kill somebody yeah and I said
to myself down yeah all he has to offer
me huh is the fact that he's willing to
kill somebody on my behalf and I asked
him I said bro that ain't all you
offered me is it he said nah I'm telling
you all do you think is supposed to do
whatever I said but what if I don't want
you to do whatever
uh-huh like I want you to do whatever
cuz we allowing you to do whatever push
your family Jeff no but kind of puts you
in jeopardy and also puts me in jeopardy
yeah no I like a guy with their energy
either teaching the kid you could teach
them to love for mine right that passion
is just in the wrong guy the passion
right for sure because now all the black
world kids around me now
they went from that energy to feeding
their families growing being bigger
creating oh you know being somebody so
other people can look up to so they
looked at total that's where I come from
left over for you right
I'll kill for you I'll die for you Wow
can you imagine that and you're doing
yeah I mean we don't even have a
contract with you make sure if he died
the parent family it's gonna be taken
care
yeah in his mind it's just his belief in
his mind he believes if I do that for
you you gonna do that
Estela say hey are you gonna do it all
right and maybe yes this is Graham but
let's have understand it don't expect
[ __ ] planning I did my ancestory did you
do yeah
recently I'm a [ __ ] from the Congo oh
really
you got heart about cousin I'm gonna get
from the Congo ain't that some [ __ ]
Congolese this water at water today huh
the Congolese these dudes kill gorillas
with their bare hands
yeah well I'm so strong you know for
sure you know that
man you didn't matter done yeah come
believes you won't find a whole bunch of
mics over there Wow but that energy is
like fearless yeah yeah conquerors is
taking on a really straight no straight
up like they will literally go
toe-to-toe with a gorilla and win
what Fela tooth to my boot to within the
Congo I'm a booty with the Congress I
think that was in Bob way if I'm not
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm bad with
names I'll be guessing I'm bad with
names with a warrior Congolese our
warrior people huh they're worried they
definitely worth your Congo Congolese
the Warriors Ghanians
from Ghana those guys are warriors good
guys from the gym worries more night
like Nigeria side but then he just I
don't know the Niger Delta all those
guys are like you just soon as you see
him they just look like do you know the
Haitian what 1790 did there was no slave
everything that Spartacus no one they
stole they took their freedom it's never
been done history of slavery tell us
about it look I'm talking about doing
I'm 1790s it was a guy named Bookman he
started
the Revolution in Haiti and I guess
dessaline finished it I saw after
Bookman that I think it's a salt Lola
cheer he took over the revolution then
he died never dessaline dr. Shalini talk
over and he's liberated the people but
in order to liberate this is so
interesting this is what was so
interesting about this so they got their
freedom right any other country in the
world any and any other country with a
European country what it did that they
they have been armed they have been
looked as heroes nobody's ever done that
before so the European nations they
starved them out they beat listen who
they be they beat the French they beat
the English they beat the Americans
right the Spanish right at the same time
therefore for superpowers and they beat
them never been done in the history of
slavery every kind of like every
colonial effort to kind of take him over
to his Davis team Wow I think had a tube
Ethiopian bloodline all right listen
Solomon in the Bible I had no I had no
idea that people don't even know we're
talking about Mike's man Mike is super
smart yeah cuz people don't realize even
the the course of religion the route in
where it start is right there Ethiopia
yeah it's enough interesting in the
Bible right I'm just stupid thousand
fifty no listen yeah I'm black but I'm
beautiful Solomon said that this is
hundred thousand years before Christ you
know I mean there's nothing new Under
the Sun
he says he's black and beautiful yes you
know we think that Senator James Brown
made up me that black is beautiful this
is Solomon the Kingdom the most wisest
and wealthiest King in the history of
kings
you know I'm black but I'm beautiful wow
this here anything in the Bible just
mind-boggling to me and I just learnt
that recently
go hearing that was mind-boggling you
know that super crazy man it might tell
you that yes he hasn't told me that yeah
with you yeah hell yeah
listen hey don't mention them don't
mention is a great businessman and
listen right clearly peep game though
the biggest common list either your but
African intercom men can you believe
that
but caught a black man won't get a
chance to call on the white [ __ ]
in America white mother won't talk no
black businessmen totally this black
[ __ ] on the corner of this suit
Africa speaking the French you know the
King's English intelligent as hell
uh-huh people send money to this account
and spray this said the money you ever
watch that show Chris Hanson How To
Catch a Predator how do these black
African [ __ ] swindle II
sophisticated white European
[ __ ] imagine white [ __ ]
won't even talk to me
no time hey European to say but what is
it is you have to say I believe in legal
rights he's black but he's a person what
is it you need to know get all the
information they may know that [ __ ]
bankrupt yeah super smart I used to
always say big is use that energy for
positive positive but then I start to
realize they really didn't have a choice
because the system don't allow them to
grow so they just utilize that
intelligence however they can to support
this measure we laugh until you make a
joke about these monkey [ __ ] from
everything negative
they run circles around us Americans hey
listen man I went to Russia one day
right patrice lumumba has the whole
college what she has the whole college
patrice lumumba cups are so bunch of
african graduating from the university
of like 1988 and i was like why are all
these educated guys and we is we don't
you know we all have no relationships
with them right we all disenfranchised
we make fun of one another yeah that's
that divide and conquer Matthew that
many of you work together a loved one
and I don't forget about this imagine
just imagine that like and it's funny
because I always think about how African
Americans are always here protesting
always crying are not being treated
equally and equal rights whatever the
case maybe not and then they don't even
realize that okay cool
if I'm not happy here let me just travel
till I find the place well just go back
to Africa let's go back just imagine
just no seriously just go back to like
just imagine if every African American
here not all of them but just the ones
that complain about uh-huh not being
treated properly because America was
never made for black people anyway I
mean it's no secret right just imagine
if you go back home invest your money
take your resources with you
in your knowledge and just start build
from scratch I'm surrounded by a whole
bunch of people that's with you all that
looks like you that actually thinks
maybe the way you think and there is
nowhere or any place where you can use
lies having an excuse by being held down
by the white man yeah oh no I think
different is hook I don't think like
America I think I have a place in
America you have place everywhere am i
contagious America's and no matter where
you go in the world you got a place
there because think about it cuz Chinese
people to me the most brilliant and have
the best system when it comes to that
right if they're not being treated fair
they're not gonna make a big post on it
because they make their money in America
in America any moment they feel any want
to go home they got a home they know
they got a home that they accept it is
their home the issue is in America
African Americans don't haven't still
accepted that Africa is their home so
they haven't put no time and investment
towards that interesting you follow
think about it the Jews they know days
really they know it's not a question
we're only people that don't claim long
wait the only ones only once it's really
interested you know so and then we have
my big exam the second biggest content
why everybody goes back of course the
history and and I hate to keep bringing
it up because it sounds like no excuse
but you yeah it goes
the difference is we know better today
it's not like my huh we know better
it's not a matter of history history
can't affect us today because we know
different right and and now that but
we've already we've already coexisted
with what we thought was our enemy we
realize we become our own enemy because
we're the ones actually holding
ourselves down from it cuz we still work
with everybody we still work with every
nationality we still mate and have
babies and create families with every
nationality like we're already embedded
within society to live and have a free
you know opportu like everybody else
it's just a matter of where you choose
to invest it or where you choose to be a
utilize to express that opportunity and
we just haven't embraced home because I
guarantee you man today African
Americans embraced home they whole
existence and future would change think
about him I think about the shame of
Africa but that's but it's all miss all
brainwash and naturally because like
pretty much uh-huh most I'm ashamed of
the projects any moment he can get out
of the projects they only go and get out
of there but just imagine if they flip
that script say you know what I would
have to leave the projects I just got to
fix it yeah cuz they all paint over it
they don't have no basic bills
I mean if it's really a man I lived in a
slum like a crowd this little bit of
come thank you so now I'm gonna get a
project slum
right the projects is a birthing drug
dealers that's making $100,000 a week
and you mean to tell me y'all couldn't
come together put $10,000 apiece repaint
the walls put carpets over new like you
can hook up the projects like up in
condominium that's worth a million
dollars a unit with the kind of money
that comes today but nobody says let's
come together and do it mmm like nobody
so it's no different than that it's just
that's just the project's now imagine
the continent where you can have your
own high-rises have your own cities
movie theaters golf courses resorts grow
homes and like you can do all that there
it's yours to do it but nobody will come
together man we got like think about the
billion dollar corporations
they're most likely entertainment
lifestyle fashion sports or influencers
right we make billions and billions and
billions of dollars for these
corporations I'm talking about African
Americans uh-huh okay yeah all these
athletes yeah all these raucous
comedians you know imagine if everybody
including entrepreneurs now and I said
you know what we all go back to African
we just gonna fix that for ya what state
would America be in and we take all our
money and resources with us uh-huh
it'd be a lot less um will not be able
to survive people don't trust African
banks but that's because nobody puts
their money there we can't answer people
they trust it we have to trust him we
got to create the infrastructure but
Africa haven't given us any good reasons
over the years because there's nobody
there to give the reason Mike right now
me and you opened up a bank in Africa
you don't think Nick is a banquet
yes of course they will cuz they know if
you lose five dollars imma give it right
back to you they know I got it no you
got it that's security there I'm uh
that's why we're Michael I'm a great
believing that I don't know people like
when I had my crew besides you know if
you didn't know who I was you wouldn't
know who the boss would be because
everybody looks then back to the top
everybody's dressed like a boss and
that's how crews should be taking care
of everybody should be taking care of
why anybody should be treated with
respect and dignity and taken care of
and that's how you that's how you create
a team imagine doing that throughout the
community and not only that you could
vote who you what kind of cop prowess
your community now right but you need to
have another understanding of the vote
right caps and you're coming you come
for only black cops and you're Puerto
Rican cop in your community if you
understood the power with your vote yes
so train your voice that's so true man
but a problem fortunately in urban
communities we just don't think although
it matters no because we've been beaten
down over the year before we got in that
community before we moved from another
community beat us down in that community
and right before we get our head
the boom in this company they stopped
beating us down again right they'd break
our spirits they kill our kids in the
streets they kill our hopes what is our
purpose now yeah and your dream is gone
once you can later I'm even if you went
in you know committed a crime page a
time yeah you come out continue to be
punished for the rest of your life even
though you've already went in yeah sir
hater i serve the time for what it is to
climb you're committed honesty I think
once you serve it this you shouldn't
even exist anymore me person no will be
shoe because we should always deal with
adversity well we know what's gonna be
there's no easier way all right what I'm
saying is if you like prime example if
you cut class of school and you have
after class detention uh-huh after you
go to detention you build a crime you
don't stay on your record or we cut
class so you know you've done the time
you shouldn't have to pay for it no more
but I think a lot of time thick right
and I understand about think about time
it's my consciousness is at that level
where I think we imprison ourselves we
do yeah we allow ourselves cuz I'm one
of those guys I'm different I grew up
like and I grew up around old Jewish
communist [ __ ] you know red sister for
everybody even though I didn't go to
school
anybody with intellect so I learned how
to talk like them so it appeared that I
know how to talk about [ __ ] never
went to school you know but I'm we just
saw who we are
yeah you know it's but the answer's no
we are but nobody accepts that and you
we consider it as why all day yeah every
asset is a why so what do you think the
solution is to waking more people up how
do you wake people up anyways people are
yeah it's like I want to stay sleeping
I'll come up right the thing is you
can't really get into a head of a person
s pinakbet experienced it uh-huh
the only solution really is the youth
you got to start from a whole nother
generation I teach them moving forward
but this generation is already
pertaining like you said it's a cancer
now we all we all have cancer it's no
way
you can change someone's my state at
this time this is what I found out to
buy life
I know I found that that cancers we're
born we can't say I didn't know that and
then it just gets activated happens we
panic or something happens and you have
to baby but we're born we can't hide my
[ __ ] with it but we are with [ __ ]
germs huh [ __ ] no I'm serious with
germs
don't ask Oh Lord he's [ __ ] angry at
the world but you know that [ __ ]
germs this we're born with and I
physically born with this [ __ ] I didn't
think we can't you know it's enough yeah
actually something that I panic or
something worried if an active Lear
through cells yeah ain't that some
[ __ ] I don't think about thing away
from this I'm not gonna catch dinner
with him that don't kiss this
[ __ ] [ __ ] you Venice it's all
energy babe it's all energy it 100% is
you know anything might prepare this for
death definitely you know ups and down
the wise people afraid of death because
it's free to the old oh that's nice it
unknown it's just that um but more
people are afraid of living dude living
is harder you're talking about Mike I'll
give it to you if we grab everybody in
this room and you hold a gun to the head
and they choose if we squeeze it listen
they gonna choose for you not most
people are more afraid of death all
right they're numb they won't they won't
take the gun to they're afraid of the
gun but their conduct food they won't
change their conduct and the conduct is
causing the die right that's for sure
that's deeper that's the difference oh
no but that's not afraid to death that's
scarier than the gonna be just a thought
of death her average person if they are
in a plane and they're about to die
you're gonna pray for God to save them
hunches they're not conscious of death
right okay you know how could definitely
be glorious life is glory if I could
definitely glory if people don't see it
goes back down to faith again right
people will say they believe in God and
we'll tell you that there's a better
place when you die but they don't
believe it
no I don't believe it either but this is
what I do believe I believe that we
reach your highest potential we no
longer exist 1000% I believe that too
you know I thought I believe that's
because when you at your highest
potential you're conscious yeah from
death doesn't matter because your
consciousness you're actually invited at
that point because you're at your
highest potential isn't a world slip to
go check this out madness and I have to
worry about listening to your voices in
your head not free that it would be and
I have to listen your voice to how
beautiful you are how big your dick and
how great of a lovely or your bad nearly
as bad as ever left madness man said no
loser man him to be free from that but
what if you don't have my son huh what
if you don't have then how did you exist
how do you how do how do you create your
thoughts because I think is it's more of
an instinct than a voice we don't say
maybe we call it voices right right yeah
right sometimes my voice goes like this
you know I may go to Europe but
somewhere they came back from up I was
in Canada that's a win I did my show us
and the last minute I couldn't hear my
wife and throw yourselves tightly with I
said good night thank you and it was
like 4,000 Billy got up and it's walk to
the stage right and kind of we love you
this hat stuff and then there's another
voice in my head said [ __ ] you think you
are [ __ ] somebody should worship you
because [ __ ] do these people know what
you did this morning know what you
thought was happening last year 10 years
ago do you know who you really are
they'll know the [ __ ] you really are so
that's just some kind just ha yeah whoo
well anytime I anytime I try to think
all [ __ ] me you piece of [ __ ] the
check she makes yeah [ __ ] yeah check see
can't enjoy nothing that's still that
form of guilt that still lives in you
then yeah no doubt my arm listen my ego
is my guilt my ego is my shame mmm I
killed my Envy at my jealousy yeah well
I'm talking [ __ ] I'm handcuffing for my
my guilt and [ __ ] let it all go
yeah come on want people to know I'm a
nice guy I think they might take
advantage of me that's some [ __ ]
that's part of how you used to be though
yeah cuz now I don't care how you act
people know you're a nice guy yeah it's
gotta be hard right yeah that's what
that goes right back to the hood yeah
hey wordy spend all your time these days
man on the plane yeah but yeah in the
States I'm based in Atlanta okay place
in the world for black people hummus
[ __ ] you through all kind of black
people out there man I came to Atlanta
that's not family watching those shows
real love or looking for love alone at
Bethel and you see people so beautiful
[ __ ] I don't want to live out there my
old life is full apart right and that is
no seriously that's not healthy fish
yeah you gotta have a very strong mind
boys you got kids or the sky what got to
be so strong just come forget a super
strong way no I'm not gonna put in that
situation let's keep ass with these
white people up here in Newport girl
yeah you got to know yourself too though
yeah definitely you gotta make yourself
I mean when I left Jersey and came to
Atlanta I came to Lana before the
Olympics I was coming for the Olympics
and I believe that crazy freak Nick was
I never won that literally that's what I
have left here all my furniture
everything in Jersey
that's what happened in LA I came out
here for the 84 Olympics I never won
I said whoa and because I'm from the
East called to go over the top right
never met Philippe black girls before
hey guy how you doing funny right Oh
everything yeah he was speaking all
properly exactly what we from the girls
wear hoodies and timberlands like we'd
fight you to hang on the boys with you
yeah they wanted the boys like literally
don't hook you are I see this person
bikini and beautiful tan hey come to the
beach with everybody yeah then I go to
the beach you see [ __ ] left
away from the beach right having a ball
he's been look really good you know he's
course is very confrontational
yeah those Gators off me put on some
sand all right yeah yeah smile guys over
there greeting is actually a threat
right right you could be walking down
the street like yo what's up no listen I
started boxing I'm 16 now right so
people swimming Toby I won the junior
bigger international two people know me
that Simon Brown's though and somebody
says hi to me I say hey what's up my
smaller and then my friend said you
might you know that [ __ ] I said not
[ __ ] you sure talk to the floor right
[ __ ] gay [ __ ] you know him right
the trick is protective mechanism is put
on yourself automatically yeah oh you
said it though you can't talk to my
smile said you hitting on me a sudden
it's just weird you can't smile if you
don't know nobody don't talk to me New
York right for the west coast
a little conversation just relax we
don't relax enough if it were easy these
West Coast guys so relaxed they live
longer too you know me it's relaxed and
got my stress it's cold all these cold
my wife could do if definitely the and
then it's hot as [ __ ] in the summer is
building the city your main thing right
now
well building the city and of course we
got eight coins in beta tested now
record yeah we be announcing you know
which major exchange we're gonna be on
and probably next to more than a half or
so it's awesome like it's I'm super so
what is home though like we're
homelessness in Africa I don't exist
Wow yeah home isn't so nice enough yeah
everybody has home like not only
everybody has home and if you don't just
go to any home and they will let you
sleep like literally if if you if Mike
right now was to go to Africa and land
at the airport to have nowhere to go you
can just go through the nearest house
and say listen I'm hungry they will feed
you they were even like you haven't
place sleep they be like okay we're here
stay here until like literally it's like
that without even no exaggeration yeah
there's just different cuz the way that
their motive is all family dream huh so
there's a different really that's a
different motive you know I mean like
there's of course there's always that
survival you think that kicks in when
you when you got when you're down bad
but it doesn't affect the fact that they
treat you like how they would want you
to treat them a thumb I just freaked you
out how people got so much to love and
the only I know you sometimes write a
code is there anything else you would
have hit before we wrap this up bro what
they know okay that means awesome its I
don't even know I wouldn't know where to
start is so much going on yeah but I
know a lot of people didn't want to know
whether or not I got records coming out
yeah I know that's life in the top your
where's my family yeah so what I did on
this album I created iconic labor group
which is for labels that I've created
and each label has its own genre of
music
release I'm not for myself an artist and
I'm actually a scientist we have a conic
which is like the big pop Leibel wears a
lot of pop records all my big pop
records to be released from there I'll
be signing pop artists around the world
on there then 1/2 kilo K which is my
Latin label because I don't have all my
you know albums is coming out of there
like my first I'm Latin now my just
released called el Negrito and that just
dropped two months ago debuted number
one on the Latin trust the first black
[ __ ] to ever have a long record to drop
on the day that's your roots right so it
was yeah exactly so let's see don't
worry right boom is there's no way I had
to do yeah I had to do it so that's
beautiful then I got a condo which is
the African label which is like on
Afrobeat Moreno cultural records that's
coming out and then we also have JAMA
Kahn which is the more Caribbean reggae
Calypso which started be dropping with
the first album that's gonna be coming
out as the hip hop R&B to us which
everyone is waiting for is gonna be
probably I won't even really say right
now cuz I got a meeting this week about
the actual release date but within an
hour the next 90 days you don't be
announced when that record is dropping
you know everybody in block were so
proud of you and I am proud of him
that's still proud of you it's awesome
did you find somebody said the other day
did you find Lady Gaga yeah she signed
to my label con life yeah that's a trip
- yeah - she's pretty cool
she's killing us a supercar with the
movie right really yeah star is born it
was great it was amazing man but she was
always super cheesy she's incredibly a
360 artist I just had it all yeah you
know I mean oh so don't know what is are
they like fighters are the most of the
most successful artists is the most
insecure ones right most of what it was
mostly the most insecure that does it
true yes true is definitely true you
know some wannabe thug they crying over
two hours ago
has it never happened with suicide right
[Laughter]
yeah yeah right it's always the most
talented one and that's in every that's
and everything so many why not she was
something right what about I mean like
you pretty you were probably pretty
close to Whitney Houston yeah oh listen
to me today man Sheila says she was
touching gellick you know listen no this
is what I found out and mine was 53
years 154 when people are when people
are also um how do I say when they're
when I noticed by God and touch my glory
they also they noticed by the devil -
interesting God noticed you he noticed
you - yes yeah now the side now the
battle begin that is so true man I'll be
the toughest part because sometime you
don't know you just think there's just
hard times he met where that fight is -
see that's the most that's the hardest
one especially when you're working
towards something you can taste you can
feel it you know you're right there and
it's always these temptations and
obstacles that just stand in the front
and you can easily go to the same
success but in a whole other direction
if you just be misled by two seconds or
you lose faith for a second or you can
just stay on that path and just make a
legacy out of yourself in a positive way
it's interesting and as you as you send
those levels of start of like all the
you have access to every in axis and
possibly dream everything you could
possibly dream I know they can stop you
is you being greedy that ego man that
green what's a book you can manage that
I tell everybody success is not it's
like everybody like what is it like man
what do I got to do to be successful I'm
like bro you can do anything to be
successful it's not about being
successful it's on how you manage
success
hmm managing success is the biggest
challenge you gonna ever have
well you know when I was 13 10 years old
I would sell my soul to the devil for
success right
ya know it just appeared this is what it
was I wanted to be the greatest fight he
put sound in my mind this is what life
is about you're not the greatest fighter
work you should live right and I said
this is what I want to do and this we're
because Holly I was in this institution
sponsoring and I Lee came in one day yes
I did so my mother calling in and see
these bad kids he came in my whole
[ __ ] life changed I was just a
criminal can't wait to go back I was
stabbing people and I was just a mom for
the kid that a kid I was a monster and I
saw him in the change my life Wow yes
Swami Laden touched me there talked to a
swamp this is a turkey that was a
turning point right yeah yeah how old
were you when did you guys first meet so
listen let me explain this way that he
talked about school I'm schooling right
Tito I new teeth on them when they were
like infants ooh yes bruises them
because he was he was like the media
whenever there was an issue and you know
we're together is like that's cool
you screw together but that was a
problem you call screwy fix it that's
though but also school didn't take no
[ __ ] oh yes
all right he was like you know you gonna
say one time right so no interrupt you
two seconds so we established this was
black woman was bad right we would have
these contests we called it the one
hitter quitter right that you had to
find a biggest person walking the
biggest person walking and you got to
walk up to him and not fun but you got
it you got it lay down because if he's
big and you don't Lam down you were
trouble boy
one thing about screw [ __ ] he's the only
one in the crew that always like he had
he use like always had a zero he every
every time you not every time but I mean
we would choose dues life's 350
like we've chatted yourself you know
there's these little soft spots are you
gotta sleep man
I caught ball one time that I did drop
you know no mere crew to me sometimes
the guys even though they don't go
around it yeah these guys gonna be payin
oh yeah ain't gonna [ __ ] drain on
these [ __ ] boy boy gotta quit
what it is it was like an exercise that
gave us courage though uh-huh so say
defense so um doing all my when I got
suspended for biting all this is yeah
all my [ __ ] huh go down there and I'm
suspended I'll be at school and hang out
with all the time and they will always
get me weed and so when they were little
kids
money is the bomb and now they older so
I'm looking at them I'm watching them
grow for me as little kids be like 1390
going to Latin Quarter and [ __ ] they
looking too dressed up to look like
general they [ __ ] they looking like men
now [ __ ] they say he's in the music
business people know who he is now
saying [ __ ] this guy's can be somebody
just [ __ ] my head worst is that if I was
explaining the early his brother had
died yeah mother 30 days after yeah but
this is what the thing his mother told
him to look after her brother you know
he didn't go to the funeral I believe he
just he couldn't take it because he felt
in his mocking him at his mother down he
said take care of fun I think friend she
mother mother told me to take care of
him well yeah I was so broken out and go
to her funeral I couldn't see him
there's no way I wanted to remember him
the last way I see mom okay
and no one asked him I saw movie that
the Soul Train award right he was on he
had a car looking jakela clearly
respected gmail agree respect
handsome they were clean and then I fit
um somebody came in said Minister
Farrakhan would like to talk to you Mike
and he said I want to go with you Mike
and so we went up there seen first round
first thing he said what are you feel
about Puerto Ricans and Farrakhan said
listen the English came and took the
prize just chill out relax chill oh yeah
nobody will talk to me that way of
children you know man yeah definitely
sure it's been awesome having you know
awesome period matters podcast it didn't
feel like an interview they were just
talking yes we had everybody who we had
totally Robin just knew Campbell's new
farewell everybody hell yeah bro what's
the name of it I was gonna say call
conversation come with a nice let me
just launching I'm just love bro come on
out to econ city love the angle econ we
got all these guys on investment not
business either big guys big corporation
guys that's when you know you look like
something just passed yeah I'm so
impressive these guys image they look
like this like a big country boy
don't you everybody you know where to
find this guy
yeah just a con at everything with us
Instagram Facebook Twitter a contact
that's it
you come an entreprenuer and doing what
you do me it's just amazing you know I
don't think people really know what
you're doing people yeah really do you
think they know no no are ya good
you tell them too much what's going on
yeah you know they always say HK stop
but you're KC coming love that you know
law go to econ calm thanks man thank you
Mike we got a lot tonight 18 SEC's yeah
well [ __ ] hey everybody I hate the god
this is some good [ __ ] I see so much
money out there hey you come back bro
you come back any time bake up everybody
until next time all that Britain and I'm
Mike Tyson here
[Music]
[Music]